I think there's an idea about me that
I'm not interested in doing projects
like this sometimes they're scheduling
conflicts other times there's drama and
the odd time the talents telling the
producers to stick it where the sun
don't shine actors regret the roles they
say no to and their words every once in
a while I turned down Jim Cameron what
an idiot number one Matt Damon turned
down Avatar freaking Avatar big yikes
even if he didn't regret turning down
the movie he definitely missed out on
the sweet sweet paycheck 10 profits
offered to him by James Cameron which
would have been something insane like
300 million dollars all because he was
committed to the Bourne series at the
time now that's Integrity we're not sure
we have number two Patty considine
turned down a lead role in Game of
Thrones he said that his manager told
him it was about dragons and he just
went no thanks not realizing the show
would become such a huge deal of course
he didn't make the same mistake twice
once the prequel House of the Dragon
came up he was sure to jump on Board
number three Amandla Stenberg has no
regrets about stepping down mid-audition
process for shuri and black panther it
was incredibly hard for her but she
really doesn't regret it at all saying
these are all dark-skinned actors
playing Africans and I feel like it
would have just been off to see me as a
biracial American with a Nigerian accent
just pretending that I'm the same color
as everyone else in the movie that was
really challenging to make that decision
but I have no regrets I recognize 100
that there are spaces that I should not
take up and when I do take up a space
it's because I've thought really really
critically about it and I've consulted
people I really trust and it feels right
number four the MCU could have been very
different if Tom Cruise took up the Arc
Reactor however when he was first
offered the role of Iron Man he didn't
feel that he was being offered enough
control over the production and
ultimately said no he isn't too bummed
about it though because he finds Robert
Downey Jr to be the perfect casting when
his chance to play the character came up
again when the Multiverse blew wide open
sadly he already had scheduling
conflicts oh and it was never even a
thing yes Kevin feige admitted to
discussing it in the very early
preliminary stages but it never went
anywhere perhaps they have bigger plans
for Crews number five imagine Tom Cruise
being the Iron Man to Leonardo
DiCaprio's Spider-Man all we're saying
is end game would have turned out
differently we're thinking a Jack and
Rose Titanic moment here well Leo turned
down the opportunity to play the web
Slinger in Sam Raimi Spider-Man back in
the day by back in the day we mean the
2002 version Leah admitted I didn't feel
ready to put on that suit yet we didn't
realize Toby Maguire and Leo were the
same age number six Helen McCrory was
originally cast to play Bellatrix
Lestrange in Harry Potter however after
discovering she was pregnant the role
went to Helena Bonham Carter instead of
course mcrory eventually came back to
the series to play Narcissa Malfoy
number 7. Aaron Taylor-Johnson was
feeling The Sting from a project he once
turned down Deadpool 2 not because of
that movie in particular but because of
its director David Leach who offered him
the role he said no to Meanwhile further
down the track came a project he really
wanted to do yep you got it bullet train
he really had to fight for the role
because it's fair to say David wasn't
too thrilled about the actor anymore
David told him get in line buddy there's
like 10 other actors who want this job
and they put a bigger name than you do
at least
so Aaron said number eight Oscar Isaac
turned down a huge role one you'd expect
he'd expect would be big but no biopics
were just on the verge of becoming huge
when he heard about Freddie Mercury and
Bohemian Rhapsody he just
think anyone would want to see it but
he's kind of content with it uh sort of
saying I think I could never have done
what raymie Malik did I just think he
was obviously everyone thought so he was
great but that was a funny one where it
was just my thinking was so like you
could just watch him on YouTube why
would anybody want to watch somebody
pretend to do him you know number nine
Lily Allen's reason for turning down
Game of Thrones is a pretty good one she
was nearly cast alongside her real-life
brother Alfie Allen who played Theon
Greyjoy however supposedly in the script
it's said that the character unknowingly
wouldn't realize it's his long-lost
sister she said I would have had to go
on a horse and he would have touched me
up and [ __ ] once they told me what was
entailed I said no thanks
yeah that's fair her brother disputed
this statement so who knows what's what
but she would have loved to be brought
on the show as a musical guest instead
head number 10. Emma Watson turned down
the lead in la la land because the
Beauty and the Beast live action was
shooting around the same time and was a
ton of work for someone who's an actor
first and a singer second or third or
fourth
and I was like I kind of got to be all
in Emma also turned down Cinderella
because she just didn't feel that the
character was a good representation of
herself we feel like this was a Natural
Choice number 11. while we're on the
topic of Beauty and the Beast Beyonce
turned down a role in the film because
it wasn't Beauty and the Beast and
plumette that's right she just found the
role too small and we can't say we blame
her Beyonce is a star not a feather
duster but she's still looking to the
Future for more musical opportunities
Beauty and the Beast director Bill
Condon had worked with her previously on
Dream Girls but it just wasn't meant to
be number 12. Jessica Chastain was a
contender for a role in American Hustle
Jennifer Lawrence's role the role that
won her an Oscar unfortunately there
were scheduling conflicts with Miss
Julie It's gotta be hard seeing somebody
else win that Oscar do you think Jessica
would have been up for 1-2 had she have
taken on the role number 13. Jennifer
Lawrence may have landed the role in
American Hustle but she had to turn down
the role of squeaky squeaky played by
Dakota Fanning in Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood Quentin Tarantino said that
Jennifer Lawrence came down to the house
to read the script because I wasn't
letting it out and afterwards we talked
about it a little bit she was interested
in doing it but something didn't work
out but she's a very nice person and I
respect her as an actress yeah we blame
X-Men number 14. Alan [ __ ] didn't
regret much of anything when he turned
down Harry Potter not even his words he
straight up told the producers to f off
and we can't blame him they were
offering him less money than Rupert
Everett who was also contending for the
role of the
rude do you think he's eating his words
we don't think he's eating them isn't
this just the way of Hollywood though at
what point does it stop being about
talent and start being about star power
number 15 Rachel McAdams was the first
choice to play pepper pots in Iron Man
however she was already cast in state of
play and The Time Traveler's Wife and
just couldn't take on the project no
hard feelings of course because she
landed her role in the MCU as Christine
Palmer not too too much later sounds
like choosing roles can sometimes be
like winning the lottery do you think
the casting would have worked out better
in a universe without scheduling
conflicts let us know who you think is a
better fit for the part in the comments
oh and hey thanks for hanging out with
us here at the things